As I mentioned earlier, the data is
formatted in a few different ways, and
we want to make it consistent with
three numbers, a dash, three numbers,
a dash, and four numbers.
To do this, we can use the formula tool
but we need to do it in two steps.
We first have to tackle
the symbol before the numbers and
remove it entirely.
To do this,
we'll use the replace function.
Choose the phone field in
the output field area, and
select the replace function.
The string becomes the phone field,
the target becomes the open parenthesis,
in quotation marks, and
we replace it with two quotation
marks with nothing in the middle.
When we run Alteryx, we can see that
this has fixed the first character and
removed it.
Next, we need to add a second formula
to fix the character after
the first three numbers.
We can use the replace C-H-A-R
formula here because we're
going to replace both the closed
parenthesis and the forward slash.
And we're going to replace
these with a dash.
We'd select the phone as
the output field again and
from the functions, replace car.
The string field is the phone field.
Then where it says y, we replace
this with the closed paren and
the forward slash in quotation marks and
we replace the z with
a dash in quotation marks.
And this will look for either the close
paren, or the forward slash, and
replace it with a dash.
And now our data is standardized
to the proper phone number format.